counselors we're now live on youtube
thank you chris uh good morning all and
welcome to team bridge district
council's
licensing and regulatory subcommittee
all participants taking part will be
taken apart remotely
and will be live streamed to youtube
with the exception of where there are
confidential or exempt items which might
need to be considered
in the absence of the media and public
i'm glad to say there isn't
so we'll move on well live streaming
please make sure all microphones are
muted
when not speaking to avoid any
background noise levels
and if you wish to comment please raise
your hand and wait to be called you
don't need to raise your electronic hand
as i can see everyone
just raise your hands or so and when it
comes to a vote
the officer will read out members names
and please say if you are voting for
against or abstaining the licensing
manager will outline the applications
and we will hear from any applicants if
presence and then members will be able
to ask questions
once members have heard all the
applications and are happy
that they have all the information that
they need the committee will adjourn to
a private session
live streaming will be stopped and then
democratic services will confirm once
the meeting
is private members are then be able to
discuss the applications
and applications the applicants will be
informed later that day whether the
request
has been granted and a full decision
will be given in five days
uh i'd like to introduce people now my
name is rob hayes i'm the vice chair of
this committee
we have beth tipton who is democratic
services
we have um debbie rosenberg who is the
licensing officer
and we have her fellow councillors and
colleagues councillor chris
clarenson councillor lorraine evans
and i think that's that i think we'll go
straight to the agenda then i
want any apologies no apologies chair
thank you are there any declarations of
interest at all
none that i can see so we move on and
look at the applications um is the first
applicants
in the waiting room yes just letting
them in chair
thank you
thank you first we'll go to um
agenda item three which is a request for
a 12-month
extension on the hackney carriage
vehicle
which is a sharon i believe
just check that yes the volkswagen
sharon w
uh registration wj07 wxy
debbie
thank you chair um yes good morning
everyone uh the first request
is from mr street for as you say a blue
volkswagen
sharan registration wj07
wxy this vehicle is now
14 years of age the vehicle passed its
mot
on the 18th of february this year with
no advisories
the vehicle was viewed by myself on that
day
and photographs have been included with
the report
and the vehicle also passed its depot
inspection
on the 8th of march so chair committee
asked you to determine this request
uh thank you uh debbie is there any
questions from demi from members
no um would the applicant like to
comment at all
um only to say that um i think the
vehicle speaks for itself that it's in
good condition
um well looked after so in our opinion
is
as good as any other taxi on the road
and could do a good job
right uh are there any questions for the
applicant to tour from the members
i can't see anything no uh thank you for
your attendance then
okay thank you if you could go back into
the waiting room
okay thank you thank you very much
now going to item 4
which is a request for a 12-month prime
higher extension
for
i can't see what the vehicle is now oh
it's a chrysler
um is the applicants in the
can you bring the applicant forward
please debbie um
just joined chair thank you
to you debbie thank you chair
um so this is um an extension request
from mr lim for a white cries love 300c
registration klc1117
which is 15 years of age the vehicle has
a current mot
um which expires in august this year the
the vehicle actually passed its
inspection on the fifth of march
um as you would see from the report
this vehicle love was last presented to
committee five years ago
and i'm sure the applicant would add any
other information that you require
for this one thank you are there any
questions
to debbie from members
i can't see chris oh yeah
you muted
sorry i was unmuted as a member of this
very small committee
can i just point out that i have to keep
flipping
from um the the um
the zoom meeting onto the actual agenda
thing
put up the thing and go back so it's
very very difficult to answer very very
quickly
uh when i'm when i'm doing that that's
that's the reason that
i'm a bit slow but i'm followed
following intensely and
uh if i go off zoom
i go into the agenda on the ipad you see
that's how i'm following it so
i hope you just take allowances for that
thank you yes thank you chris
so uh no questions from me thank you um
is uh anything you'd like to add uh the
applicants
is that kevin lynn
you're muted
hi can you hear me now thank you yes
thank you yeah yeah good morning
um yeah the reason um uh this vehicle
was on last at five years because it's
part of our limousine fleet
um it does weddings and it's only
actually licensed
we only have the license on it to do the
school proms um
so it doesn't do any mileage which is
why they put instead of every year they
put a five year on it last time
um as i say it does it doesn't do
airports or anything like that it's just
used for weddings and proms
um but yeah the vehicle was immaculate i
say this year
i mean with with the covert and that
it's done about 200 miles in a year
um other than that is stored in a garage
you know heated garage but
um but yeah it's absolutely immaculate
obviously we'd like to continue
licensing it
um just purely for the school proms
which
um you know i don't know whether we can
do it on a longer term rather than keep
coming every year now or whether we can
do it like the limousines where we
they're longer term but um and
say it's not a regular used car it is
used as a limousine vehicle
thank you for that are there any
questions there for him
no there's only one slight
concern i have i've noticed all the i
don't know it's got nothing to do with
the current mot
even though it was an advisory about the
um parking brake
it seems to have a history of having a
fault with it
no it's not it's not a fault it's uh the
chryslers have got inbuilt
um hub in a very small shoe in the hubs
they're never very good handbrakes but
um but no i mean you can see on the last
report
uh you know only went for a test last
week um then it was i think it was 20 27
something like that which is you know um
16 is the
minimum so it's well over um it's just
you know to be honest it's automatic as
well and due to the
like the miles it doesn't do is sort of
yearly service on it really but
um you know it doesn't do any miles to
to to you know
because you never use the handbrake on
them you know it's one of those really
but um okay thank you that was no
concern there as i say it went for the
test last week and it flew through the
brake test no problem
thank you for that any other questions
from members
no okay well thank you uh mr lynn if
you'd like to go back into the waiting
room
okay thank you for your attendance this
morning thank you
now going to item five
and item five and item six so we can
take those together i'm sure because
they're
owned by the same owner
is uh mr smith ready is he in the uh
waiting room
beth uh he's in the meeting now chad oh
thank you
right uh i'll bet you bet
where um i debbie oversee you debbie
yeah thank you chair um okay so the next
two applications as you say
are both from mr smith um these two
requests
are to change from a standard size plate
um to what we call the executive small
ones
um for dw11cab
which is one year and 10 months old and
wf-20 eet which is 11 months old
um both of us are currently licensed
with us
and um as said in the report uh the
applicant
would like small plates to use for
executive use on these two vehicles
thank you chair thank you debbie mr
smith would you like to add anything to
that
i can't see mr smith
is he here beth he is chair
sorry um we don't seem to be able to
hear you at the moment mr smith
i can see that you have unmuted but the
audio doesn't appear to be working
yes i can see you now mr smith
no unfortunately we can't hear you say i
can see you haven't muted yourself
but there appears to be some technical
difficulties
right um we'll press on then are there
any questions
to the license any questions to debbie
at all
no i have no questions either um i think
we can proceed with this one then
uh beth if you can ask mr smith to
return to the waiting room
we will then deliberate on these
applications
um thank you chair so the applicants
will return to the waiting room just to
clarify for anybody watching
on youtube that we will stop live
streaming now so the committees can go
into private session to discuss
obviously the applications and to make
their decision
um we won't be coming back from from
that session we won't be streaming live
again
once once the decisions have been made
the meeting will finish
and all applicants will be informed of
the decision later that day